let's here's for uh from some people in
the audience we are going to take some
calls via discord which you can find at
davidpakman.com
slash discord
every day can be good or bad on the
discord we never know what to expect
let's start today with dave from new
york city why not dave welcome to the
program
hi mr pac-man how are you i'm doing well
thanks
great um thank you for taking my call
this is actually my first time calling
in and i just i wasn't even sure but you
said please directly get to the question
um i noticed that um and this this ties
into my question
um you seem to have a very good amount
of sponsors on the show um including
blinkist and
some others
i actually did try fume and it's kind of
working out for me but i wanted to ask
you if you have any advice for people
with a pattern of self-sabotage
uh
and this has to do with the sponsors
well well i would say because um there's
blinkist and there's privacy
and there are things that i i feel would
help me and they seem to be excellent
products
you're a guy who sabotages yourself is
that what you're saying
yes i have a pattern of self-sabotage
and i think that one of those things is
recognizing the services that you've
recommended and not being
proactive enough about
following up on them even though i think
that they would help me and that ties
into a general self-sabotage
issue and i was wondering if you have
any advice for people who have chronic
self-sabotage patterns well i think the
most important thing would be to get a
therapist i mean that's really that that
would be the most important thing uh
more than anything i could say but so in
what ways do you sabotage yourself like
in work and in relationships
um not so much in relationships i've
i've um i've always felt and i know that
i'm a great partner when it comes to
relationships but
um
in terms of work
yes sometimes um my my current job i
have a certain level of freedom and
i
i kind of show up where i want when i
want
um and sometimes that leads to me not
showing up even though i need the money
um there are other issues where in terms
of i do have a therapist and i do take
medication but i'm not always i'm not
always wonderful about the consistency
of doing so and i just logged on to
youtube and i saw that you had a video
saying taking your calls in 15 minutes
and i figured i would try yeah well
listen i appreciate the call i i want to
be careful not to get out of my lane i
think you're doing exactly the right
things by working with a therapist and
and that is exactly what i would keep
doing but i'm sure you're exploring this
but i think figuring out
why the self-sabotage is happening would
probably be extraordinary useful as a
first step in figuring out how to
control it
thank you do you have any book
recommendations because it sounds it
sounds like you're an avid reader yes on
my website go to davidpakman.com click
on recommendations hundreds of book
recommendations there by category
okay i'll look into that alright dave
from new york city thank you so much for
the call very much appreciate it